Traductor: Alberto Rojo
Revisor: Javier Yunes
Hace un par semanas
me hicieron una entrevista en la tele,
y me llamaron un rato antes
para maquillarme,
y la maquilladora -Margarita-
que me había visto en videos anteriores,
me pregunta:
"¿De qué signo sos?"
"Positivo", le digo, provocándola un poco.
"Dale no te hagás el vivo", me dice,
"seguro que sabés cuál es tu signo".
¿Y por qué querés saber mi signo?
le pregunto, provocándola de vuelta.
"Porque los signos dicen mucho
de las personas", me dice
"pero vos sos científico,
así que seguro
que no creés en la astrología".
¿Y por qué te crees que los científicos
no creemos en las astrología?, le digo.
"La verdad no sé muy bien", me dice
"porque la astrología
tiene mucho de ciencia.
No solo es ciencia lo que se aprende
en las facultades", me dice.
"Hay mucha arrogancia
entre los científicos
que descalifican a la astrología,
sin saber que es una ciencia distinta
de la que aprendiste vos."
Tenés razón, Margarita,
cuando hablás de la arrogancia
de los científicos,
que son bastante egoístas.
Pero la ciencia, como empresa colectiva,
es de una gran humildad,
con mecanismos de control del fraude
y de la deshonestidad académica.
Y hay una ciencia.
Quiero decir, la ciencia es como un juego,
con sus reglas.
Y así como hay un fúbol y hay un tenis,
hay una ciencia.
Yo le podría llamar ajedrez al fútbol
pero Messi no va a estar muy de acuerdo.
Más aún, Margarita, le digo,
yo creo que la astrología
no está de acuerdo con ciertos rasgos
y ciertas reglas
que definen al conocimiento científico.
"¿Cómo cuál?", me dice.
Una diferencia importante, le digo,
es la actitud
que tiene la comunidad científica
respecto de su disciplina,
comparada con la comunidad de astrólogos.
La astrología no fue revisando su teoría,
a medida que se fue incorporando
conocimiento nuevo,
y a medida que fueron apareciendo
problemas irresueltos
dentro de la teoría del momento.
La astrología
es indiferente a los acertijos,
y se resiste a compararse
con teorías alternativas, le digo.
"¿Y cuál es una teoría alternativa
para vos?" me dice.
Bien, ¿no?
La psicología por ejemplo.
¿No te parece posible
que mi personalidad está determinada
por mi genética,
o por mi entorno,
más que por una estrella lejana
cuya luz veo hoy
pero que ni siquiera existía
cuando yo nací?
Más aún
hay estadísticas en poblaciones grandes,
sobre todo en el hemisferio norte,
que muestran rasgos distintos
según el día de nacimiento.
Por ejemplo, los de Libra
suelen ser un poco más equilibrados
que el resto.
¿Eso es por las constelaciones?
O porque es el final de la cosecha,
hay mejores nutrientes
y todavía no llegaron
las enfermedades invernales?
Todo apunta a lo segundo.
O los nacidos en septiembre,
también en el hemisferio norte,
en promedio,
suelen ser más exitosos.
¿Es porque son de Virgo?
O porque el período escolar
en el hemisferio norte
empieza en septiembre,
los nacidos en ese mes
suelen ser los más grandes de la clase
tienen más confianza en sí mismos
y en promedio
tienen un mejor desarrollo cognitivo.
"Pero Alberto,
La astrología tiene ecuaciones,
vos sos científico,
te tendía que interesar".
Sí, es cierto que la física
usa la matemática,
y misteriosamente
la matemática es la descripción,
es el lenguaje para describir
las regularidades del mundo.
Pero no todo lo que es
matemático, es científico.
Yo podría decorar una torta con ecuaciones
y eso no la convierte
en una torta científica.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
O puedo usar algoritmos sofisticados
para la cábala
o para ganarle al casino.
La matemática es un lenguaje,
y en todo lenguaje
se pueden decir disparates.
En la física, lo que hacemos es comparar
una teoría con la evidencia
y, si la predicción no está
de acuerdo con la evidencia,
revisamos la teoría.
Es decir, la física es vulnerable
a que se la pruebe incorrecta,
"Si, más o menos",
me mira con cara Margarita
"Pero la Luna tiene un efecto
sobre las mareas, ¿o no?".
"Y nosotros somos agua,
o sea que algún efecto tiene
que haber sobre nosotros".
Es cierto, hay un efecto
pero cuantitativamente insignificante,
le digo.
Si tengo en cuenta el tamaño de la Luna
y la distancia a la que está de la Tierra
el efecto gravitatorio sobre mí
cuando la Luna cruza el cielo
es el mismo efecto
gravitatorio del Obelisco
cuando cruzo la 9 de Julio.
El número es el mismo.
Y con los planetas
es todavía más chico el efecto.
Y esos efectos no son tenidos en cuenta
por los astrólogos.
"No es tan así", me dice Margarita.
"Porque hay mucho astrólogo
chanta por ahí."
"Vos lo que tenés que hacer
es ver el video de Fulano de Tal,
que es un capo, un tipo muy reconocido".
Entonces agarré el celular
y empecé a bajar el video del capo.
(Risas)
Y mientras tanto, ella me googleó,
y vio que yo había nacido el 15 de febrero.
(Risas)
"Acuariano tenés que ser", me dice.
(Aplausos)
Pero sabés que no soy de Acuario
en realidad,
y me mira "¿Cómo?"
Los días no duran lo mismo
que las noches, le digo.
Eso se debe a la inclinación del eje
de giro de la Tierra sobre si misma
respecto del plano de giro de la órbita
de la Tierra alrededor del Sol.
Sin esa inclinación
los días durarían lo mismo que las noches,
no habría estaciones.
Ahora, aún con esa inclinación
hay dos días especiales durante el año
donde esa aguja está perpendicular
a la línea que une la Tierra con el Sol.
Esos son los equinoccios.
Los dos únicos días del año
en los que el día dura lo mismo
que la noche: equi, nox.
En tiempos de Tolomeo,
en el equinoccio de marzo
del otro lado del Sol
estaba la constelación de Aries,
y ese era el punto cero del Zoodíaco.
Ahora resulta que esa aguja invisible
que apunta hacia la Estrella Polar
no está estrictamente fija
sino que por sutiles razones gravitatorias
describe un cono
y la punta de ese cono,
completa un círculo
en unos 20 mil años, 26 mil años.
Eso quiere decir que cada 2 mil años
el equinoccio se desplaza 30 grados,
que equivale a un mes.
O sea que en realidad, ahora,
los que nacieron el 21 de marzo
no son de Aries sino que son de Piscis,
y yo que nací en Febrero
no soy de Acuario
sino que soy de Capricornio.
Y le digo, todavía más
si dos personas nacen
en el mismo lugar,
el mismo día,
y a la misma hora,
pero una al año siguiente de la otra,
difieren en su coordenada cósmica
en 35 mil kilómetros.
Es decir que no hay una unicidad
entre el momento de nacimiento
y la posición de las estrellas.
Margarita no se mostró interesada
(Risas y aplausos)
Entonces,
yo empecé a ver el video del capo.
(Risas)
Me llamó la atención
el uso de información basada en evidencia.
El tipo dice:
"El universo existe
hace 15 mil millones de años,
hay miles de millones de galaxias,
el universo se expande".
Esa es información reciente,
que forma parte de la revisión
de la visión científica del mundo,
que no modificó la visión astrológica.
Y eso es un punto crucial
en las pseudo-ciencias:
el uso de información científica actual
para validar una visión antigua
ya descartada
por la visión científica del mundo.
En otro momento el capo dice que:
"Todo está conectado con todo",
importando, o contrabandeando
una idea de la física cuántica.
Una de las contribuciones
fundamentales de la física cuántica,
es la indistinguibilidad de las partículas.
Entonces por qué discriminar
entre un átomo de una estrella lejana,
y un átomo de un objeto que nos rodea.
Porque la astrología
se apoya en la idea aristotélica
de que somos el punto focal del universo,
y de que el mundo celestial
en su pureza cósmica
es distinto del mundo terreno
hecho de fuego, de tierra,
de aire y de agua.
Pero hoy sabemos que eso no es así,
todo está hecho de átomos.
Un átomo de carbono de una estrella lejana
es idéntico a un átomo
de carbono de mi piel,
y de un átomo de carbono
de una roca en Marte
de la carcaza de plástico
de un electrodoméstico de la cocina.
Es decir que,
la influencia que puede tener
sobre mi destino
un átomo del anillo de Saturno
es el mismo que puede tener
la licuadora de mi abuela.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
De modo que si tenemos en cuenta
la interconexión total,
yo no solo tendría Saturno en siete
sino que tendría el lavarropas en Aries.
(Risas)
Y lo digo en serio.
Más aún, hoy sabemos
que nos somos el único sistema planetario.
Hay otros planetas con estrellas,
y somos el cielo de esos planetas.
Y así como ellos, hipotéticamente
determinan nuestro destino,
nosotros determinamos el suyo.
Margarita me dice
"¿Pero no hay fe en la ciencia?"
En el fondo me estaba haciendo
un planteo sutil.
Porque nosotros en ciencia aceptamos,
sin demostración,
que las matemáticas son el lenguaje
que describe
las regularidades del universo.
O sea que le dije, en parte sí
"¿Ves?" me dice.
(Risas)
Sí, tenés razón.
Pero no es una fe en el sentido bíblico
de Hebreos 11:1, que dice que la fe
es la evidencia de lo invisible.
A medida que la ciencia fue indagando
en la anatomía del cosmos,
la ciencia fue haciendo visible
un esqueleto causal mucho más rico
y mucho más complejo
del que postula la astrología.
Y gracias a ese conocimiento, hoy tenemos
satélites, vacunas contra la poleo,
celulares, luz eléctrica,
anestesia contra el dolor de muelas.
Es decir,
la astrología, en el fondo,
tampoco pretende ser un sistema
basado en la fe
sino que más bien, es una fe
disfrazada de ciencia.
"Si soy de Acuario soy creativo".
Ahí estás usando una relación
causa y efecto.
O "es prácticamente imposible
que una Luna en Libra
se abra completamente
a su ascendente en Escorpio
a partir de los dos años y medio".
¿De dónde sale el fundamento
de una frase como esa?
que la tomé literal
de un congreso de astrología.
Para mí está basada en una idea,
en cierto punto soberbia,
de que el universo está pendiente
de mi existencia y de mi psiquis,
cuando en realidad,
cada avance de la ciencia
enfatiza nuestra humildad en el cosmos.
No tengo nada de especial,
soy apenas un ser más, de una especie más
en un planeta más,
en la vastedad de un cosmos
al que le soy completamente indiferente.
Esa es la lección de la astronomía,
que en un principio
estaba emparentada con la astrología,
pero de la que fue,
gradualmente diferenciándose,
despojándose de los dioses
y del pensamiento mágico,
pero no porque no haya magia
en la realidad.
La magia de ayer
es la tecnología del presente.
¿Sabés qué creo Margarita?, le dije
Yo creo que parte de la responsabilidad
está en un sistema educativo
que instala la idea de una ciencia
como algo férreo, frío e irrevocable,
que en lugar de acercarnos
nos aleja de la poesía de la realidad.
La ciencia es esa minería de precisión
de los misterios del mundo,
que nos enriquece el asombro,
que nos conecta, y nos unifica.
La dicha de entender
puede ser profundamente espiritual,
Margarita.
"Pero Alberto, a mí
la astrología me sirvió!"
Te entiendo perfectamente, Margarita.
A mí por ejemplo la música me sirve
como un lenguaje que toca mis emociones.
Pero yo a un preludio de Bach
no le puedo pedir que me cure
una hernia de disco.
En cambio, cuando estoy eufórico,
o melancólico,
o triste,
un preludio de Bach
me da una paz y un alivio tan grande,
por eso te entiendo
que puedas usar la astrología
para resignificar el pasado
o para aliviar angustias del porvenir
que no podés entender del todo,
pero Margarita yo te pido personalmente
no uses la astrología para cosas
en las que no se aplica.
La astrología no nos va a ayudar
a encontrar la nueva fuente
de energía renovable
o para hacer un puente.
Por eso no la uses para determinar
la fecha de operación de apéndice,
o decisiones importantes de tu vida.
Por favor, no la uses para eso.
Me miró con cierta aprobación
mientras me sacaba el delantal
porque me tenía que ir a la entrevista.
Y yo sentí que habíamos llegado
a un punto de convergencia.
Nos saludamos
amablemente
y me fui caminando por el pasillo,
cuando iba caminando
siento que me dice: "Alberto
vos tenés la Luna en Leo,
te lo apuesto."
(Risas)
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)